a lot of people stereotype that I show
with kids in it is a kid show like
especially when the kids are some lead
characters it was sort of like a
personal thing for me I just really
liked it I didn't know like take off so
fast traveling around the world people
recognizing I was like so many people
like I met Matt Damon I met Amy Schumer
Amy Adam they are just the Parker oh why
don't you Ryan Reynolds she was super
cool Leonardo DiCaprio and Meryl Streep
for the two big ones for me oh hi I
really should like I know I would I was
like oh well Barack Obama he was like
hey I know you guys are you think I
watched you guys I saw you guys dancing
at the enemies you guys have good dance
moves
[Music]
near the end of the whole process when
we were auditioning we went in this room
made this entire wall like filled with
posters of jaws et The Goonies all those
newbie communities it was like our
homework to watch those movies
the clothes are incredible the
hairstyles of crazy walkie-talkies those
are the best hanging out paint hello
hello I can just call it up your friend
that would be pretty cloud would
probably be even mad a lot it's actually
really fun to work with them because
when I was doing to do one episode 7
were with the walkie talkie I kept
accidentally hitting Millie in the face
with a giant antenna and when actually
on this ceiling it would hit the top of
the ceiling as we were shooting the next
season is a year later 11 is obviously
back the boys they are all together and
we have our new cast members
Sadie sink and dica Montgomery the great
thing about this season is you get to
see insight to each character on the
road you're going to see a lot more into
the lives of how the characters are
coping with what's been going on there
are going to be some challenges that the
characters face that aren't real that
are disturbing I think they're all very
emotionally scarred they feel alone
because their best friend is back and
he's not acting like their best friend
anymore
you've changed I think the season will
be a lot more dark a lot more more
oriented I think people are gonna like
it better be first
[Music]
no I would not want to live super kawaii
be scared of abusing it
I mean telekinesis great but you get
drained afterwards my goodness yes
it's amazing although I wish she could
read people's mind I wish like she
guessed she can go into people's minds
but I wish you could read them I think I
do want say I'd be normal normal I mean
I'm not normal but normal since in my
own skin hey everybody happy Friday
surprise promo for strangers being
season 2 we haven't really seen a whole
lot since that big Super Bowl trailer
but it is a really funny way to show you
how off the chain
11th powers are going to get like she
slowly got more and more powerful as
season 1 got on now that she's come back
from the upside down which we still
don't know how that's happened like you
just see her in the season 2 trailer she
opens her eyes and it's like okay I
guess the Eggo waffles lured her back
but will is featured much more
prominently and he's been coughing up
slugs since the end of season 1 so when
that season 1 trailer says the world is
turning upside down in the cast the crew
the producers have been talking about
how much crazier this vessel Hydra
looking thing is going to be compared to
the demagogue and you're just wondering
how much they're going to bleed the
upside down into the normal world like
you see shots like this and it's almost
like the entire world is going to become
the new upside-down and like some broad
intelligence or whatever organism really
has sway in the upside down is now
pushing more into their world so one of
my favorite things to do when re
watching the season is you just pay
extra attention to what they're talking
about when they're playing that Dungeons
& Dragons game it's sort of a prelude
for how the monster is going to appear
how they're going to face it what their
challenges are going to be so even
though they trade on a lot of classic
80s tropes a lot of Spielberg a lot of
Ridley Scott they're going way more
Ridley Scott and season 2 I hope that
they bring back the Dungeons & Dragons I
feel like they have to it just feels
like such a big part of the series but
let me know what are you most excited
for in stranger things season 2 and if
you didn't know it's dropping on the
most appropriate day it could possibly
drop on this year it's coming on
Halloween so yeah it's not going to be
for a while but that's why they're all
wearing the
Buster's uniforms because this is
Halloween when this picks up so it's
Halloween in the series and it's going
to drop on Halloween in real life but
what will happen is is because Netflix
is just going off the charts with its
original content between the Marvel
stuff between the animated stuff it's
producing this stuff they've been a lot
better about dropping new content
throughout the year instead of just
dumping it whenever it comes like here
you go here's all the episodes we're not
going to bother to promote it so there
will be stuff at Comic Cons this year
there will be stuff throughout the
summer but really the big thing this
summer for them is going to be defenders
so they'll be promoting that because
it's dropping it August then this comes
in October and they just revealed that
the Punisher series is going to drop on
Netflix in November they didn't say what
day but because Punisher is a military
event and that's such a big part of his
story I feel like they'll probably drop
it on Veterans Day which is November the
11th on a Saturday but because most
Netflix series drop on Fridays they'll
probably just drop it on the 10th so
November 10th is the early prediction
but I think the latest would be
Thanksgiving they always release a lot
of big series around holidays so we'll
see I'm just expecting Punisher on
Veterans Day this is October 31st and
defenders is August 18th so there's
actually a ton of really awesome Netflix
series dropping so just leave all your
requests for stranger things bonus
videos if you guys want me to start
doing more defenders stuff let me know
there's going to be a lot more defenders
footage before new stranger things
season 2 but I always try to keep my
eyes open when new stuff drops so
surprise surprise there's some new
spider-man homecoming I'll post then
I'll post my Wonder Woman Easter eggs
the ending all those videos so make sure
you go see Wonder Woman this weekend
because it's badass while you wait for
that you can click here for the new
stranger things trailer and you can
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight
you